but you see my feeling these days is
that you can write screenplays from
anywhere and wherever you live you can
write screenplays that you need it i'll
tell you a story that i think that
divides that and i was living here still
it sold a script called original sin to
synergy to anyone i sold that I think
for a million to Billy and about poor by
once after the sale that was and we were
in Hawaii vacation and he calls me knees
he says I'm the grape said he said you
know the I just heard that there is
corporation for television bought a
script called original said yes and it's
your squid it's your script exactly or a
script your manual typewriter because
that's all i can do is my little finger
sentimental though it said that's how i
said really yeah and is there isn't well
but there's a different name up there's
some guy whose names that's always the
guys well believe me I've got a team of
lawyers looking into this to see what
tell this guy years and he called me
back home things later he say he said
he's a mailman in Chicago who lives with
his mother and he is in a screenwriting
course hmm yeah he said well in his
screenwriting course they were teaching
original same so this guy took the
script see rocks did still have my
typewriters for his old name on it Kaiba
taneja in Chicago agent Chicago
nollywood they sold it for six hundred
reason so the more or less to which you
don't have to live here you live
anywhere
you